- [Voiceover] Let's Scream for Ice Cream
serves three scoops of ice cream
in its signature cone.
And they draw a picture
of it here over here.
Each scoop is sphere with
a radius four centimeters.
Or, with a radius of four centimeters.
What is the total volume of
ice cream served per cone,
to the nearest cubic centimeter?
And they want us to use pi
as being approximately 3.14.
We know that it's not exactly 3.14,
it's 3.14159 and just keeps going
on and on and on and on and on forever.
Some people memorize thousands of digits,
thousands of digits of pi,
and even that's just a,
there's an infinite
number of digits to pi.
But anyway, let's see
if we can tackle this.
So there's three scoops of ice cream.
Each of them is a sphere,
so this bottom one you can't fully see,
'cause it's into the cone.
And they each have a
radius of four centimeters.
So, if you go from the
center of the sphere,
to the surface of the sphere,
that is four centimeters.
So, what we really just
need to do is figure out
the volume of one of these spheres,
one of these scoops,
and then multiply by three,
because we have three scoops,
and they all have a radius
of four centimeters.
They all have the same volume.
And to do that, we have to remember
the formula for the volume of a sphere.
The formula for the volume of a sphere is
volume is equal to four-thirds
pi r cubed.
Where r is the radius of the sphere.
In this case, it's gonna
be four centimeters.
And pi is pi, the famous number.
The ratio between the circumference
and the diameter of a circle.
And we're gonna say, for
the sake of this exercise,
we're gonna say it's 3.14.
With a lot of calculators,
you can get a much more
precise representation of pi.
But we're just gonna use 3.14
'cause that's what they told us to do.
So the volume of one,
the volume of one sphere
is going to be four-thirds times,
we're gonna use 3.14.
3.14 for pi, times the radius cubed.
The radius is four centimeters,
and we are going to cube it.
And if you do four centimeters,
and then you cube it,
you're gonna get the
unit centimeters cubed,
Or cubic centimeters.
Actually, let me just do that.
Four centimeters cubed.
So this is going to be the
volume of one of our spheres.
And then we have three of them.
So, let's multiply to get the volume
of all of them combined.
Let's multiply this times three.
And actually makes our
calculation a little bit simpler.
Because we have three divided by three,
and so we are left with,
we are left with four times 3.14.
If we were more precise we
would just say this is pi
right over here, this is
just an approximation for pi.
And then four centimeters
cubed, let's see,
four cubed is 16 times four, it's 64.
So this is going to be times 64..
And you could also think of
us as cubing the dimensions.
So, centimeters cubed,
that's gonna be cubic,
cubic centimeters.
So, it's gonna be this
many cubic centimeters.
So, let's think about it.
So, it's going to be, we
could do this by hand.
See, four times 64, that is 256.
So, it's gonna be 3.14
times 256 cubic centimeters.
But we're allowed to use
a calculator for this one.
So let's just take a calculator out,
and let's just multiply it out.
3.14 times 256
is equal to 803.84.
And they tell us to round to
the nearest cubic centimeter.
So, 803.84 cubic centimeters,
if we round to the nearest centimeter,
we're gonna round, or round to
the nearest cubic centimeter,
we'll round up because we
have an eight right here.
So, it's gonna be 804 cubic centimeters.
So this is approximately 804 cubic,
804 cubic centimeters.
That is the volume of these
three spheres combined.